we left the story last time celebrating
the 30th anniversary of the Macintosh
the thing that used to win a rage Steve
Jobs it's wonderful Steve it's cute but
he's a bit of a toy what is it for and
here's the answer
it was the apple laserwriter I should
apologize right at the outset we tried
everything we knew to get hold of an
original apple laserwriter one but we
just couldn't this one is a fairly early
apple laserwriter - this one is dated
1988 there's one behind me that we've
got off eBay we might refer to that one
a little bit later on the one behind me
is even earlier it's 1987 as opposed to
1985 but we did the best we could
Steve Jobs had the foresight to invest
very heavily in this other technology
that came out of Xerox PARC John Warnock
Chuck cash key founding Adobe and having
this new two-dimensional graphics
language that was also suitable for
being a page description language for
laser printers and typesetters it was
called postscript Jobs invested very
heavily in this he bought Adobe stock
and I think John Warnock told me he gave
them a million and a half dollars in
upfront royalties because again Jobs is
far sighted and he got it right he
thought that the combination of the Mac
with the laser writer would be just
magic they couldn't get it to market in
time for the launch of machinate g4 it
had to wait her whole year so we're
talking early 1985 despite locating
these two laser printers the thing that
causes problems with these things when
they get as old as these are is the
power supply it's not that the power
supply doesn't work it does but the one
part of a laser printer cycle which is
really demanding it's not so much
running the logic inside it two types at
the page it's the fact that when you
roll out the page you have to in the end
fuse the toning with heat onto the paper
to make it stick
and to cut a long story short the power
supply's on this one and on the one
behind me and I was so tired
they just soaked furiously if they're
asked to give up seven amps just like
that but I will turn it on and hopefully
Sean might be able to zoom in and show
you what happens the green lights flash
as its booting up you end up full of
hope the green light on the left will
start blinking it's just checking that's
all though it's logic board there is
quite happy PostScript fonts being
jer-bear oh dear it's blinking red and
we've tried everything we know so sorry
we can't actually run the thing for you
however when it was working and wasn't
sulking
this is your boot up sheet and it is
just a playful thing done with proper
fonts and full computer graphics you can
probably see at the top that there's a
capital P they told you that it's
PostScript there is much use down have a
sans serif fonts and those of you who
know about these things will say yes it
is Helvetica reporting even that there
is rs-232 a serial line rs-422 now
that's an adaptation of the iso standard
that in the apple domain was called
apple talk it's a medium speed network
it's better than serial line appletalk
can do 230 kilobits 230 kilobits is okay
but it's not Ethernet early Ethernet is
10 megabits way faster again so if it
got a network of Saul's but not a very
high speed one it's telling you how many
fonts there are inside it it's got 35
built-in fonts the laser 801 only had 13
and then down at the bottom it's telling
you that this particular one is equipped
with 2 megabytes of RAM now that was a
lot in those days and it wasn't there to
support a multitasking gameplay machine
it was there simply and solely to
support font rendering to the laser
printer drum and the chip inside that
laser writer as we'll see later on
was over the 68000 family just like it
is in the Macintosh but run us a much
faster clock speed by the time it got to
this laser printer over here it was
faster still it was a 68 Oh 20 and boy
did you need it
you really needed that to get it to work
at all the problem with a laser printer
is that if you've got your page or bit
mapped and rendered and ready to go and
you know an a4 or us letter size page
you're talking about a megabyte you're
talking eight megabits worth of black
and white dots but once inside here you
tell the drum to start imaging stuff on
the paper and you start rolling the
paper out you are committed you can't
say stop I want to do the bottom off a
bit later I'm running out of additive
compute power you can't do that when you
gotta go you gotta go
some of you have seen the previous
videos on the 202 typesetter can sort of
draw the contrast here the 202 have the
great advantage that it was all done in
letterbox
strips the imaging onto a reel of paper
and if you after you turn one letterbox
full you wanted to go away and have a
cup of tea before you did the rest well
then you could there's no problem but
not with this it's utterly page based
when you roll you've got a roll you
can't stop and it was a huge demand to
be able to keep up with the rollout
speed of this and believe me it was only
just doable particularly with laser
router one technology there were 13
fonts inside the earlier one when I say
fonts you know what would the 13 have
been full flavours of times roman
regular bold bold italic and italic four
flavors of Helvetica ordinary oblique so
on four flavors of Korea the fixed-pitch
font bold bold oblique ordinary and so
on and one mathematical symbols for font
three four to 12 plus 1 is 13 and
they're built-in as we shall see Steve
Jobs who done a graphics arts degree at
Reed College I think in Oregon although
he dropped
to help before he got his degree you all
about typefaces their names all this
kind of stuff and he said John John you
know we've got to save money can't we
just go with with clone font you know
things that look like Times Roman or San
serif Helvetica and John told me he said
look Steve I hope I've got this the
right way around you drink Coke don't ya
how do you feel Steve if I offer you a
can of Pepsi and the look of horror on
jobs its face and John said I think I've
made my point Steve if we're gonna
position this as the serious future of
typesetting we've got to have proper
phones that people have heard of so we
won the day and I think he was right he
largely did help to convince the
typesetting community that this thing
although it had problems at the
beginning was on the road to
revolutionising typesetting well I've
taken out the logic board from the laser
writer too that is behind me and this
one is dated in 1987 and it's a real
eye-opener it was really taking me back
here on my left your right is the RAM
two megabytes worth of it
the laser eyes the one had one and a
half but they found out pretty quickly
they ideally needed more this is
soldered on to the board all of these
bits make up your two megabytes here
here one two three four five six seven
eight eight roms and at the time that
came out in the laser eye to warn those
eight roms constituting half a megabyte
of firmware inside here was a world
record no prizes for guessing that's in
here is the PostScript interpreter a
minimal little operating system that
could reach stuff down the serial line
or access extra fonts on disk so there's
a postscript interpreter is in here plus
embedded at this stage the 35 fonts
rather than the 13 well there's a CPU
chip this one being in the 1987 model is
still a motorola 68000 16 bit if we look
inside that one had been a little bit
younger and later it's moved on to being
a 68 Oh 20
that stage over here is the much-vaunted
appletalk over at this side of the two
possible sockets that gave you the
option for a serial line that would run
a standard up to nine point six kilobits
but I think there was a switch setting
here you could do to make it run at
nineteen point two obviously if you're
doing serious work with this you use the
Apple talk whenever you could Steve Jobs
was very happy with it running over
Apple talk preferably with just a
roomful of Mac's or sharing the Apple
talk but those of us who bought one of
these things for 7,000 pounds were not
really happy unless it could be used
with other computers so there was a big
growth industry shortly after this was
released in linking Ethernet networking
to Apple talk with names like spider box
to whatever you to do that so yes it
eventually became shareable you could
justify the huge expenditure in buying
the thing so here we are in early 1985
John Warnock and Steve Jobs rehearsing
and discussing how they were going to
present this winning combination what
was going to be the demonstration
document that really convinced people
and made everybody say WOW well don't
forget Steve Jobs passionately wanted
the Macintosh to be taken seriously as a
business computer and between them I
don't know whose idea it was they came
up with this idea what more boring but
more convincing document could you have
than a tax form it's not the main US tax
form is one for supplementary income
this thing rolling out of that laser
printer John told me they timed it at 1
minute and 15 seconds which the greater
legendary Steve Jay said John I can hold
them I'm good at holding people in my
laser glare at making them concentrate
but I cannot hold them for a minute and
15 seconds is there some way you could
speed it up John realize of what he had
to do given his knowledge of the
PostScript interpreter inside here was
effectively to do something that we in
computer science now call by various
names unrolling the loop
flattening the code making it be in line
code for those of you that have ever had
the misfortune to blunder into opening
up a PDF file accidentally in a text
editor if you look very closely at this
you will see it looks like the birth of
PDF it isn't pure PDF but it's very
similar so is this the birth of PDF yes
in 1985
having to do this gave John the idea
that this was the way to unroll
PostScript to make it longer but faster
and more predictable as to how many
pages it will produce because the
problem with PostScript in its pure form
is you often couldn't predict how many
pages it would produce whereas in PDF as
you know you can
so here again was history in the making
unrolling the loops flattening the code
making it be in line code and what this
broadly means is if you have absolutely
groundbreaking it's a completely new
computing paradigm